jason you came here before um to
basically let's just get to the bottom
line give away cold hard casts
yeah
it's taped to my body it's shaped all
over
all over my body i have a couple
thousand dollars that i would like to
give away here today oh my god i'm gonna
ask i'm gonna ask some trivia questions
that's what i do on my show cash at your
door tuesday nights
11 o'clock on e network um i think you
forgot to say hit show so thank you very
much
um okay well it is time for a game we
play here on this show which is a hybrid
called cash at your seat
[Applause]
we've selected a few audience members to
participate and first up is de conte tia
are you here de conte here she is
we're so happy that you could join us
today thank you for having me i'm so
excited thank you for being here well
i'm turning it over to our esteemed host
jason oh wow all right dakota how are
you good how are you i'm very well thank
you do you like money yes that's
fantastic because if you get this
question correct you will win 250
dollars
are you ready
here we go now in honor of rachel being
here today the question is about her all
right rachel uh has a dog food line
my question is
what is its name
is it a
kibbles and bits b blue buffalo c
nutrish or d
moist and meaty
i cannot believe i just had to say
moist
and meaty
decantee what is it
i'm gonna go with nutrish
[Applause]
congratulations and thank you so much
for winning because if you had lost i'd
just be really upset me too yeah
congratulations to kante thank you so
much
[Applause]
how are you i'm amazing how are you good
so excited to talk to you okay all right
all right thank you christine
totally five hundred dollars is on the
line right now five hundred dollars
we're going up get this question yeah
we're going up right it was 250 lucky
you were now 500. okay uh adele have you
i don't know who that have you who's
adele um i've been heard
i'm kidding i know who that was okay
adele just released a new uh single
right uh easy on me fantastic song which
of the following is not the name of one
of her songs a rolling in the deep b
when we were young
c hello or d genie in a bottle
everyone just laughs
well i
like i know i cry a lot to rolling in
the deep while driving
so that was adele do you want to talk
about that or yeah
okay
no and
um jeez
okay i don't ever see a genie in a
bottle genie in a bottle is your answer
and the correct answer is
you need a
bottle together
[Applause]
your your home to to me you guys are
awesome
that's pretty fun right
yeah yeah giving away money is fun i
tell you well you are the host of cash
at your door
we've been giving lots of money away for
the whole hour and we've spun the name
of your show into cash at your seat so
we're gonna call our final contestant
monique waterman
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you i'm trying
to be a little fun today now i heard
that you and your husband founded a
non-profit organization um would you
please tell us about that oh my husband
and i we met at 11 years old and we saw
a non-profit organization called east
flatbush village inc because we want to
just make sure our youth are taken care
of and their families holistically will
wrap around services we don't prevent
gun violence so we take a proactive
approach through athletics sports
academics anything that's going to get
our family to a next level and thrive in
the community
[Applause]
[Music]
i love your husband i love what you do
thank you so much we have four children
too
what's one tip um that you can give us
today that we might be able to take with
us on how to be a good person
just be the mentor you needed when you
were younger
[Applause]
i i could have used the mentor when i
was younger too so i'll take that one to
heart i love it
love it okay monique are you ready to
play casually
i think so yes do you know you are the
last one so far we are three for three
let's make it four for four if you win
if you get this question right it's good
for a cool thousand
uh monique the holidays as you know are
just around the corner and baking season
is upon us tis the season and i do love
a good pie
[Applause]
it says that right there they literally
they wrote that for me i don't get it
though what does it mean
love a good pipe anyway okay so uh so
let's test your pie knowledge monique
what is the official
state pie
of florida is it
coconut cream pie
apple
pie pecan pie or pecan pie depending on
where you're from
or key lime pie
well apple will go with new york so i
don't think so uh
photo key lime pie
[Applause]
that's your official answer yes is key
lime pie is your official answer for 1
000
the state pie
of florida
can i be honest with you i
it's key lime
[Applause]
and everybody's
doing all the good stuff that
everybody's doing is going to be on our
website so if you'd like to learn more
contribute whatever it is go to the
drewbarmore show.com so we can talk
about people like you money thank you so
much
[Applause]
i mean that was fun you really make this
show just so much better it's like
how do i top this uh you're very sweet
by having him back and handing out a lot
of cash
exactly i'll come back listen it's your
money so i don't care
[Applause]
this is just such a pleasure cash at
your door airs tuesday nights on e it's
so awesome thank you so much jason thank
you let's just keep doing this because i
love it
[Applause]
thank you so much co-pilot all right
thank you so much
for choosing to spend your time here we
make this show for you so please take
this energy with you and we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]